[Applause]
you're watching swipe and here's what's
coming up on this week's program I meet
the comedian behind a database to help
people with mental health issues
Alex delves deep into parts of the web
you probably haven't been to and our
games reviewer sends us his thoughts
from one of the world's biggest gaming
events that's all so karma the next 10
minutes or so but before then let's take
a quick look at some of the tech stories
that made headlines this week Elon
Musk's joined more than a hundred tech
leaders in warning the United Nations
about future killer robots
the Tesla chief and others signed a
letter urging UN to ban the development
of autonomous weapons that could be used
by despots and terrorists saying once
this Pandora's box is opened it'll be
hard to close speaking of intelligent
robots his long with 56 fingers that can
play the piano tio tronic Oh is among a
variety of sophisticated droids at the
world robot conference in Beijing the
retail giant wal-mart is linking up with
Google home to offer voice-activated
shopping it opens up a new front in his
battle with Amazon which currently
dominates the boy shopping market
pirates personal assistant Alexa turns
out Angela Merkel's a fan of gaming the
German Chancellor opened the annual
Gamescom event in Cologne this week one
of the world's largest events for video
games she acknowledged the importance of
the industry by saying games were a
driving force for innovation we'll be
bringing you more from Gamescom a little
bit later in the show and Formula One is
entering the esports arena
the competition begins next month with
gamers around the world battling is out
to be the best virtual f1 driver and be
crowned the Formula one eSports Series
world champion now there's a new
database it's called hub of hope it's to
help people struggling with mental
health issues find support near them it
was set up by a charity called chase the
stigma and that was set up by Jake Mills
a comedian from Liverpool you can just
click find nearby services what kind of
services are these these are charities
community groups they're basically not
the NHS it's not to replace doctors or
counseling or any other services like
that puts to work alongside it it's to
say that that is help available the one
that's here it will give you the address
and the details and the open times but
if you could select more it will show
you where there is information about
them and all their contact details
what's your reason for doing this what's
the personal story behind it I myself I
suffered with depression for probably
over a year and I didn't know where to
turn for help I didn't know what help
was available i bottled everything
inside and I didn't tell anyone and that
kind of led to me eventually attempting
to take my own life and it was only when
I came through the other side and I
started to start to talk publicly about
that that I realized how many of the
people were going through the same thing
I was suddenly people come into me
complete strangers from all over the
country asking me for help people saying
I'm struggling I don't know where to
turn and I didn't know how do you think
technology in a wider sense is helping
to change the stigma around mental
health particularly with social media I
personally have seen the two sides of
the coin I've seen it horrible the troll
the pressure the social media kind of
pretends that people live but then at
the same time I've seen how everyone can
come together so we want to use that
side of technology to say even if you're
in the house in your bedroom you don't
want to ever leave
you can still access oh you're a
comedian how do you combine this with
your comedy work I think comedy is such
a good tool and that you can talk about
things and laugh at things that maybe
people are scared of we're onto doubt
it's selling tickets to a comedy show
about depression so you joke about
mental illness I talk about my own
because yeah well the best type of
comedy is things that everybody has and
everybody in the world has mental health
everyone has mental health so the best
thing that you can do is use what we all
go through the stupid things that we
might think the stupid things you might
say and what's your ultimate goal now
the aim with the app and website and
database we want the hope of hope to be
everywhere anyone who offers any form of
support or advice can register to be on
a hope of hope no one charges to be on
it no one charge us to use it it's just
all free it's just one place to bring or
help support together time for something
a little bit different now but stay with
us it involves cake
we often hear stories about the dark web
how many of us really understand what
goes on in those parts of the internet
that Google doesn't take us to well this
week alex has been investigating dark
web deep web surface web bill an awful
lot of terms thrown around and it can
sound quite complex but we it's a piece
of cake
bear with me is he like a piece of cake
the internet has layers there's the
surface web you can think about that the
top layer of icing here it's accessible
through internet search engines then
underneath that this big chunky sponge
that's the Deep Web it's the majority of
the web the kind of pages like your
password-protected email account bank
details but in part of the Deep Web like
this layer of icing in the sponge is the
dark web like the Deep Web it's not
accessible through search engines but
here there's an additional element
special tools are used to make sure you
don't know who's hosting the site you're
accessing and they don't know exactly
who you are either
the most commonly visited sites on the
darknet are probably these lis
markets these black markets that buy and
sell almost anything illegal narcotics
recreational drugs fake passports
counterfeit money and increasingly a
huge amount of ransomware the sort of
stuff that was used to infect large
parts of the NHS a couple of months ago
in May a huge ransomware attack swept
indiscriminately across the globe NHS
systems were hit hard appointments were
cancelled as staff were locked out of
their computers so how exactly does this
dark web work what it relies on a
special browser called tor this
anonymizes users and the hosts of sites
so the individuals cannot be traced now
that in itself is perfectly legal this
technology was actually developed by the
US Navy but darg websites will only
grant you access if you use tools like
this and it's on the dark web that we
find these illegal marketplaces this is
one of the websites where things are
being sold you'll notice that there is
feedback so there are stars from
customers who are happy and customer
reviews customer reviews are available
pretty much everything that you would
find on a legitimate marketplace is
reflected here in one of the illegal
marketplaces and the language used on
these sites sounds rather familiar what
does 100 % satisfaction guarantee mean
if you were not happy with your purchase
we will replace the database or refund
your order so that's the language you'd
expect on a normal website selling
normal goods but this is this is illegal
what they're doing absolutely
this is selling stolen goods this is
selling access to people's lives for
criminals to exploit to make more money
so we've seen a lot of content on here
that is illegal and we know there's
upsetting content on here so is it a
case of the dark web bad and the surface
web is good you will get people who
obviously are criminal and are looking
to disguise their activities online but
you get ordinary people who are using
the tor browser to give them there a
sense of security a sense of anonymity
and that
the catch with the dark web the same
tool that masks criminals protects
people where there isn't a free internet
so a closer inspection this shady dark
space has more layers of its own Alex
Morgan Sky News it's time for that part
of the show where we tell you what's
worth knowing about in gaming right now
and this week we're focusing on news
from Gamescom arguably europe's biggest
gaming event and our reviewer rick has
been there in germany any major games
convention the chance to play the latest
games before they actually come out is
once roars the public and they certainly
all queuing behind me before the Duty
World War two it's one of the better
demos I played here it's 40 minutes of
multiplayer gameplay in war mode and it
has sound a basic shape throughout of
u-boats but the big thing is is that
these guys they are queuing to play but
you will be able to play at home if you
already pre-ordered the game so you get
to play the demo that all these guys are
curing poor results
I'm in the business design center of
Gamescom at the moment was kind of the
calm of the eye of the storm that is the
whole convention and it kind of is a
good and ironic flick on Jurassic world
evolution the game that was actually
announced just before the show started
it's by the planet coaster roller
coaster 20 ohm guys frontier
developments and same can expect to
build your own to running around ruining
your guests and mr. Park members it's
going to be fantastic comes out next
year in the summer of 2018
there are a lot of driving games here at
Gamescom project cars to Gran Turismo
sport but undoubtedly my favorite is
also motorsport seven
[Music]
it's 4k HDR mixed with 1x and please say
when it comes out it's got so many modes
and you can even customize your driver
this year which sounds weird but it
works it allows you to put anything on
your driver and you can even have like
some jumper over your suit in things I
know it's very very cool but ultimately
it comes down to the driving experience
in the pores of does it face the biggest
hardware announcement this year's going
to come 2017 involves this little guy is
the project Scorpio exports 1x the 4k
HDR gave me the powerhouse of a console
that comes out on the 7 November this
particular one has a grain dated tin and
it's specifically designed because it is
a day 1/3 order bonus there might be
some still available but if not the x1 X
also comes out on that day and you can
get one of those there's also the
Minecraft Xbox one s which is really
really well designed but I particularly
like this controllers there's the
creeper one that comes with it but also
the piggy which I really love that you
can get separately away that's the point
here well that's it for this week's
episode join us again for more swipe
next week and in the meantime follow us
on Twitter at Sky News swipe bye-bye
you